ارتفعت اسعار العقود الاجله للخام
الامريكيه اكثر من ثلاثه دولارات لتسجل
خمسه وسبعين دولار
للبرميل جاء ذلك بعد ان اعلنت في مجموعه
اوبكلاس عزم الدول المشاركين فيها على
تخفيض مستوى الانتاج المستهدف لالعاب
القادم بواقع مليون و400 الف برميل يوميا
بحسب البيان فان اوبيك بلس اتفقت على ضبط
المستوى الاجمالي لانتاج النفط الخام الى
اربعين مليون و460 الف برميل يوميا وذلك
اعتبارا من الاول من يناير 2024 وحتى
نهايته في حين اعلنت كل من روسيا
والسعوديه والكويت وسلطنه عمان والامارات
والعراق عن تمديد التخفيضات الطوعيه
للانتاج الخاص بها حتى نهايه العام 2014
ما يعني ان التخفيضات الاجماليه ستصل الى
اكثر من اربعه ملايين برميل يوميا
اقل وزيروا الطقس السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان ال سعود ان ارتفاق الذي
توصلت اليه مجموعه اوبيك بلس غير مسبوق
وفي مؤتمر الصحفي مشترك مع عدد من وزراء
الطاقه في مقر اوبك في فيينا اضاف الوزير
السعوديه وان قرار اليوم يساعد على تعزيز
فرص استقرار الاسواق ومنع التذبذب الحاد